Dr. Elia Gourgouris,
thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you for having me.
I appreciate it.
It’s good to be here.
It’s going to be so much fun.
I’m going to spend the next
20 minutes learning how to be
happier and how to navigate
through crisis better
because these are the two books
that you’ve written.
The first one, a best-selling
book; the second one,
I’m guessing, is already
on its way to becoming
a best-selling book.
- It's out in the market.
- I hope so. It just came out.
So, I hope so.
- It's just looking good.
- You have it next to you.
So, let me see the cover.
Let me see how it looks.
The new book is
“7 Keys to Navigating a Crisis,”
a practical guide to mostly
dealing with pandemics
and other disasters.
We’re going through a multitude
of crises at the same time
right now.
- WIth four, right?
- So, this is really morbid.
Yes. Yes.
Okay. We’re going to
get there in a second.
But first, I need to know
how to be happier
and I’m very excited for this.
So, maybe just give me a couple
of the key earned insights.
Over your decades of research,
what is happiness and why
do we yearn for it so much,
this concept?
First of all,
happiness is a choice.
Let’s make it --
And it takes work, however.
It comes easier
for some than others.
But I will tell you this.
I get to speak internationally.
I travel around the world
speaking on happiness
and wellness.
In every country,
the first question
I ask the audience is this --
if you were to ask any parent,
regardless of nationality,
ethnicity, religious affiliation,
socio-economic status, gender,
whatever, "What would you like
for your children?"
And the answer is always,
“I just want them to be --"
and then I take the microphone
and I point towards the audience,
“Happy!” you know,
everybody's --
because that’s
a universal need, right?
We are here on this earth
to be happy.
So, the easiest way,
of course, is --
you cannot be grateful
and be sad at the same time.
So, to have an attitude
of gratitude
-- and that’s pretty well-known.
What I want to
raise the bar a little bit --
because it’s easy to be grateful
when everything is going well.
That’s the easiest thing
in the world.
I say that we’re all graduates
from the same university,
the university of adversity.
And the older we get, and
the more experience we have,
the higher the degree.
So, by the time
you get to be my age,
you have gray hair,
you have multiple PhDs
and adversity in life.
Meaning, that we’re all going to
lose people we love --
our grandparents first,
and then our parents,
at some point,
maybe a spouse or a sibling,
God forbid, a child.
We’re going to have
financial crisis.
We’re going to
have health crisis,
be it cancer, heart disease,
diabetes, and so on.
We’re going to have
relationships, divorces.
Things aren’t going to work out.
So, all of these things are part
of the human existence, right?
So, the key, of course, now, is
can you be grateful
in the midst of crisis?
Can you be grateful when
you’re facing adversity in life?
Because when things
are going well, like I said,
it’s easy to be happy
and to be grateful.
But can we be grateful
in the midst of
the darkness of life?
I’m going to ask you that.
What do you think?
Is that possible even?
It has to be, otherwise,
this is going to be a very
sad conversation.
So, I’m going to say
that it has to be.
It has to be, yes.
And the key, of course,
to that is, to me, nothing bad
has ever happened in my own
personal life
and the thousands of patients --
I used to be a
clinical psychologist,
my first ever practice
in my life before I switched
over to the corporate side.
Everybody faces these things.
Some of them, multiple times,
and sometimes,
at the same time,
which is very difficult.
But to me, either you’re learning
something or you’re winning.
There’s no losing in life --
Right.
-- if you learned the lesson.
So, out of the toughest,
the most -- the darkest of times,
I’ve actually learned more
than my successes.
Right.
And then, you use those
to move forward, right? In life.
- So...
- Sure.
...don’t be afraid
of adversity because
adversity is coming.
And we’re getting it now
in spades, actually, in humanity
as we speak right now.
And I do want to go to that.
We got multiple crises.
We got the COVID-19.
We have the financial crisis
and economic crisis
as the result of the shutdown.
We have a mental health crisis.
Just in the United States alone,
after the first two months --
we don’t have the statistics yet,
from the month of May yet.
Depression, anxiety,
stress-related disorders,
up an astonishing 700%.
Seven hundred percent.
These are new people.
Not people that have
pre-existing conditions,
mind you.
These are specifically
as a result of the pandemic.
And then, of course, you have
the racial strife and everything
that’s happening in the streets
right now as we speak.
So, to have four crises
simultaneously is very unusual.
Now, I’m an optimist by nature
and I will tell you this,
that humanity may be down
on one knee and maybe
struggling a little bit.
And we’re getting
a beating right now.
But we will overcome this.
Let there be no doubt.
And I also want to share with you
that there are four types --
four personality types
when dealing with crisis.
And there’s a big differentiation
between danger and fear.
If somebody comes up to you
and cuss in your face right now,
you’re in danger.
That’s real.
Fear, however, is not your friend.
So, we don’t want
to make decisions,
whether as individuals
or as companies,
whether in the corporate world
or any organization based on fear
because those are
not good decisions.
- Right.
- So now,
let’s talk about
the four personality types.
Number one is the victim.
The victim is all,
“Why is this happening to me?
"This always happens to me."
"Poor me,” right? "Poor me."
The second personality type
is what we call the critic.
Now the critic,
regardless of
what the federal state
or local government,
or the health care
officials that --
they criticize everything.
For example, “You should wear
a mask when you go outside.”
“Well, that’s stupid.”
Okay. “Okay, don’t wear
a mask when you go outside.”
“Well, that’s stupid, too.”
Like, no matter what comes up,
they criticize everything, right?
It's like no matter --
It doesn’t matter what it is.
The third group,
we’d like to call the bystander.
They make the most noise, right?
They do and they’re very loud.
They’re very loud.
But they offer no solutions.
This is important.
The third group,
we'd call the bystander.
Now, the bystander
is a good person.
But basically, the bystander
is overwhelmed by --
and really doesn’t
know what to do.
Like, “This is a huge
wave of unknown.
I feel out of control.
My life is out of control.
I don’t know what to do.”
So, they look to their left.
They look to their right.
They look at their neighbor.
But they sit in their --
they have that deer with
the headlights look,
and they do nothing.
And all three of these
personality types have
one thing in common.
They offer no solution.
Right.
The victim doesn’t,
the critics surely doesn’t,
and neither does the bystander.
Now we get to the fourth type.
And the fourth type,
we’d like to call the navigator.
And the navigator --
and this is the premise
of this book, right?
That we all should
become navigators.
The navigator begins
with a positive attitude,
and says, “Look.
No matter what happens,
we will overcome this,”
practices self-care,
which is the first key
to navigating a crisis.
Meaning,
They take care of themselves
in order to be successful.
And then, they are flexible
and adaptable.
With this new normal,
if you think you can go on
and do business as usual
and expect to have
successful results,
you’re sadly mistaken.
Right. Right.
Everything’s completely
different right now
in the last 90 days
to four months.
And why is flexibility important?
We’d like to use the example
of the oak tree and the palm tree.
The oak tree symbolically
speaking -- think about this.
The oak tree is this massive,
strong tree that’s been
around for 100 years.
- Huge, strong, right?
- Very stable. Yup.
But if there’s enough moisture,
enough rain and enough wind
at the top of the storm,
the hurricane,
guess what happens to oak trees.
They come crashing down,
- on cars, people, homes, and so on.
- Yeah.
The palm tree,
on the other hand, is thin,
tall but very flexible.
At the top of the hurricane
150 miles, yes, it goes of wide --
it’ll go parallel to the ground.
But when the storm passes --
and think about
the storm of life,
- right? Not actual storm --
- Yeah.
-- it raises up again
and survives.
Up and down, yeah.
Up and down.
So, we’re asking people
now to be flexible
like a palm tree.
Don't be an oak tree and say,
“Well, that’s how I’ve done
things for the last 30 years.
I’m not changing,”
you’re going to break
if you stay like that.
You need to be flexible.
But Dr. Gourgouris,
I have to ask.
Because you also have
a lot of experience
working with corporates.
And you transitioned
from clinical work
to the private sector.
And now,
you’re helping leaders --
and I’m going to take
myself for example.
One day, I’m going to
have a company of my own.
And I hope to have
a thousand employees,
which I can lead that ship
wherever we go.
Now, the question is,
is it really reasonable
to try and aim for all
of the employees
in the organization
to be navigators?
Or do you want
to have some critics,
some bystanders?
Or do you really want
everybody to be
navigators here?
This is a fantastic question
and here’s why.
The critic, the victim,
the bystander. and the navigator
all exist within
every human being.
We all have those
personalities within us, right?
Yeah.
And I'll tell you,
when this first hit,
I was the bystander.
All my speaking engagements
that I had set up
throughout the world,
guess what happened? Cancelled.
- Yeah.
- All gone.
I’m like,
“Now what do I do,” right?
And I kind of feel like
a victim a little bit.
I’m like, “Oh, no!
Why is this happening to me?”
And believe me,
there are things
that the government
has done that I criticized
very openly.
I’m like, “That is stupid.”
Look, I see people driving
in their cars, sometimes,
by themselves wearing a mask.
Hello! There’s nobody else
in the car.
And here is the important thing,
I didn’t stay a victim.
I didn't stay in critical mode.
And I didn’t stay as a bystander.
I decided to do
something about it.
And the result of actually
that of the navigating
is writing a brand-new book.
I had no plans in 2020
to write a book.
Beautiful.
I had this impression
that I needed to do it
and I called my partner.
I’m like -- he’s Greek also.
I’m like,
“Costa, do you want
to write a book?
I'm going to write this book.
Are you in
or are you out, brother?”
- He goes, “I’m in.”
-  I love it.
And in 45 days,
we got the book out.
Wow!
To put that in perspective,
my first book
took three years to write.
Okay. That’s incredible.
That’s what navigation
looks like.
So, do we want
all our employees
to be navigators?
You’re darn right, we do.
No, I think that’s incredible.
Specifically -- just yesterday,
I spoke with a professor,
Dan Ariely, who’s a good friend
and a mentor,
behavioral economics.
He wrote
“Predictably Irrational."
And he said that
one of the things --
His advice to us was that
when he has a plane
that is delayed,
he sits down
and uses that opportunity
to write a children’s book.
And he only writes
the children’s book
when his flight is delayed.
So, he’s turning that situation
form a victim point,
“Why is this happening to me,” to
“Oh! I have an opportunity
to now work on a project
that I never had a chance.”
So, I’m seeing all these patterns
of the very successful people
and I’m starting to
adopt this mindset.
So, we want everybody
to be navigators,
but also -- more importantly
because of the other book, too,
we want them
to be happy navigators.
We don’t want you
to just navigate and --
- be grumpy about it.
- What does that mean?
What does that mean,
being a happy navigator?
To me, it means that
you enjoy the process.
You truly enjoy the journey.
When we talk
in the corporate world --
I started talking about happiness
in the corporate world before
all the studies
backed it up, right?
Because they used to be like,
“Happy employees? I pay them.
What do they need to be happy for?”
[laughs]
I’ll tell you why
they need to be happy.
Because happy employees,
number one,
they're physically healthier.
That means they
have less time off
because they’re healthier.
Okay.
They’re more collaborative.
They’re better team players
because they’re happier.
There’s greater retention, right?
People don’t leave.
They’re loyal.
They love where they work.
And as a result to that,
they’re more productive.
Right.
Guess what happens
when you have a
productive workforce.
Your company is more profitable.
Well, what’s happening now
in Silicon Valley?
Every other day,
we see of another allegation
or accusation of
companies’ cultures.
They’re just going down.
And it seems that company
culture in 2020 is
one of the most important aspects
that a founder has to work on.
So, where do you come
into this arena?
What's happening?
And why are companies suffering
from their lack of
happiness or culture?
Because their focus
should be where?
When you treat
your employees poorly,
guess how your employers
treat your customers.
Poorly.
When you treat
your employees well,
guess how they treat
your customers.
They treat your customers well.
There’s a direct link
between the way
that you treat people.
So, in the rush --
especially, nowadays,
with the economy
being shut down
for 60 to 90 days,
HR directors right now
are having a very difficult time
- Yup.
- because the CEO --
now, they’re ramping up
again, economy --
businesses are coming
back on again, right?
Now they’re like, “Listen.
Our revenue,
we’re behind schedule
by 60 to 90 days,
what are goals
were for this year.”
The employees need to work
two times or three times
as hard as they did before.
That’s where
their CEO is coming from.
Now, the employees,
on the other hand,
who are coming back --
and not all of them because some
of them are going to stay at home.
They’re going to refuse
to come to work.
They’ve been traumatized
by all this.
So many things
have happened
out of their control.
So, the seniors --
I call it the C-suite, basically.
Senior leaders need to
treat employees completely
different than before.
And they need to say,
“Look, I know we have to hit
those numbers by the end
of this month.
But here’s the why behind it.”
Like, they need to step up
their own game and communicate
to the employees as to, "Why
I’m asking you
to hit those numbers?
Because if we don’t,
I may have to lay off 25%
of the workforce.
And I don’t want to do that."
The enlightened leader
will use those words, and say,
“You’re part of my family.
I don’t want to have
to let go of any one of you.
I need you to work harder
so we can hit those numbers,
so everybody is still
employed next month."
And not to do it
in a fear-based mode,
where you do it,
“Or else --”
but truly do it in an empathetic,
caring and compassionate mode,
so say, “Listen,
we’re all in this together.
We’re all struggling.
None of us expected to have
almost zero revenue for 90 days.
So, we’re way behind
the 8th ball.
I do need your help.
I do need you to work 14 hours,
but I’m doing this
because I also want you to be
here at the end of the year
so we can all be
standing together and united.”
If they don’t do that
and they just focus
on the bottom line --
these people are already scared.
They’re already down.
They’re already depressed
and traumatized.
You had that kind of pressure
on top of that,
you’re not going
to hit your goals.
So, it’s sounds like
if I thought that until now
as the real test of leadership,
it sounds like, actually,
the re-opening
is going to be just as great
a test on how do you now treat --
how do you understand
and empathize
with the new situation
and your "new employees" that --
it’s not just like
you froze for 90 days
and you came back to reality.
But reality continued.
It diverted.
And now, you have
a new reality to work with.
And you used two key words.
Empathy, meaning --
in other words, senior leaders
need to show increased
emotional intelligence,
like they need a lot more than
they ever have before.
That’s number one.
And then number two,
in some ways,
you’re re-onboarding
all your employees,
like as if they’re new
because this is a new --
truly, it’s a new normal.
And people say,
“Oh, I hate to use that term.”
But guess what?
The new normal
will become the new normal
because these
are changing so rapidly,
we really don’t know even
what the fall will bring.
Yeah.
Nobody can really predict.
Will there be a second wave?
How bad will it be?
Will it happen in September
and November
when the flu season kicks in?
People don’t really know.
So, this is the reason why
it’s important to take care
of your employees now,
more than ever.
Dr. Gourgouris,
why are you so passionate
about this?
Why go get a PhD
on Psychology
and focus on happiness,
write two books?
You’re the president
of an organization that helps
thousands of people be happier.
Why? Why?
Because I feel like
my purpose in life --
and I’ve known this since
I was young man, actually,
is to make a difference
in this world.
And I feel this world
right now is really struggling.
I need to up my own game.
Like writing this book
in 45 days.
I had to up my own game
and my own expectations.
Because normally, I’m like --
I’m not going to greet like,
“Oh, whatever.
We’ll get there
when we get there.”
No, there’s an urgency
to do things right
and to do them now,
because people are hurting
and they’re struggling now,
not next November,
not in 2021 or 2025.
We need to help them now.
And organizations
need that help now.
This comes from an optimist.
by the way.
I’m not like the-sky-is-falling
pessimistic guy,
but I see what’s out there.
And I feel. I feel deeply.
So, for me, yes, happiness is
the most important thing in life.
Senior leaders need to have
a different mindset
going into this.
It’s not business as usual.
Your workforce is not the same
that it was 90 days ago.
I promise you.
So many things have changed.
So, be sensitive to that.
The words that you also used----
compassion, kindness,
understanding.
Over-communicate to the point
where your employees go,
“Boss, enough!
That’s the tenth time you told me
that you care about me. I got it.
I got to go to work now.”
Like, I know it’s kind of silly
what I’m saying,
but you know what I mean though.
- Like you have to overdo it.
- Over-communicate, yeah.
Yes, over-communicate and show
them that you truly care --
That’s the downfall
of a lot of leaders, right?
That they under-communicate
instead of over-communicate.
In other words, we can't afford
to take shortcuts
as a leadership right now.
Not this time. Not this time.
I’m really excited
for where you’re going
with your life.
I'll tell you.
I did my research on you.
You’re a wonderful young man.
And I see nothing
but success in front of you.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
One of the reasons why
I enjoy this so much,
like we spoke before,
it’s because I get to learn
of all these different industries.
And when else
would I get to speak
to a happiness expert and gain --
even if I take
three takeaways from this
on over-communication
and having empathy
for my colleagues
and employees, and employers,
and being a navigator
instead of a critic
or instead of a bystander.
I mean just those three things
are priceless lessons
that I learned,
and hopefully, my friends
who are watching
this will also enjoy.
Doctor, before we leave --
and I can't believe 20 minutes are
almost up, it's so disheartening.
Going by fast.
- Yeah, it goes fast.
- So fast.
I want to know three words
that best describe you.
Well, happiness is number one.
I mean, my nickname is,
"You’re the 'Happiness Doctor,'”
basically.
So, happiness is one.
I think there’s nothing more
important to me than family
and the family unit,
the people that I love the most.
And then, my faith.
Whether your faith is in God
or your faith is in the divine,
or your faith is whatever
you want to describe that --
We will overcome this.
Let there be no doubt.
The vaccine will come.
The drugs,
we’re getting very close
to having the drugs already.
And I love the fact that
humanity is
working together.
All the scientists
from all over the world are
working together.
We have a common enemy,
an invisible enemy.
And listen, humanity has been
up against the wall before.
This is not going to be
the end of us.
We will be better
as a result of it.
I hope so.
And even in the corporate world,
I think that’ll be better.
The working from home,
or some of the differences
that we're seeing right now,
in new ways, there’ll be
more innovation than we’ve seen
in quite a while
because that’s what crisis
brings about,
is the need for innovation.
So, that’s another plus.
So, don’t give up.
I love it.
Keep the faith. Be happy.
Okay, last question
just because it’s really
fascinating me now.
Where are we headed with
the research on happiness?
What is left to uncover?
So, we know we want to be happy.
We have an idea of things that --
of how to deal with adversity.
But what is left to uncover
on this big question of happiness?
I think the one thing that
all of the happiness, it has to do
with kindness,
because,
yes, self-care is important.
But it's --
in the end, why?
Why are we doing all this?
It’s to help one another.
I want talk to your audience.
If you’re feeling
sorry for yourself,
if you feel like,
“Man, I have to sort out --
Things are really hard
right now,”
I promise you
there’s somebody else
out there whose life
is a lot worse than yours.
A hundred percent.
Find that person and,
in act of service.
It could be a text.
It could be a phone call.
If you get that prompting,
“I need to call Michael,”
I’m not going to put it off.
I’m going to call Michael,
say, “How are you doing?”
In America, here,
the answer is always,
“I’m doing fine.”
And I’m going to say,
“No, no, no.
How are you really doing?
It’s between you and I now.”
This is what managers
need to do with their employees.
Yes.
They need to ask
the second question,
not just a token,
“How are you doing,”
because most people
are going to say, “Fine.”
I’m like,
“No, let me close the door. "
"I see your countenance.
I see your face."
"I see your eyes.
I think you’re struggling."
"Tell me what I can do
to help you.”
I think this is the Greek
part of you that’s
coming out from the --
- Yeah.
- Yeah?
Yes. It is because we love --
There’s a work in Greek
called “philoxenia,"
which means --
Philoxenia means
"the love of strangers,"
in essence.
So, we have to go the extra mile
and help those around us.
And there’s need all around.
By the way, happy people
are kind by nature.
On the other hand,
when you perform
an act of kindness,
that makes you happy
on the inside.
So, with kindness and happiness,
you can’t have one
without the other, in essence.
Maybe there need to be
more study about
connection between those two,
kindness and happiness.
I love it.
Dr. Gourgouris, thank you
so much for your time,
for the inspiration.
I can’t wait to order your book
and read it, “Navigating Crisis."
I can’t believe
you wrote it in 45 days.
That must be [inaudible]  --
I had help. I had help.
Of course.
With all the help in the world,
bringing an idea to production
in 45 days, it’s mind-blowing.
So, I can’t wait to read it.
And thank you
for taking the time to do this.
Thanks for having me
on your program.
Thank you.
Take care.
You, too.